we begin with syria where state media
say two roadside bombs have exploded
near an army bus in the worst attack in
the capital in years at least 14 people
have been killed and several others are
injured authorities are calling it a
terrorist attack no groups claimed
responsibility so far let's bring in
zaina hodo who's in neighboring lebanon
live from beirut zayn and no claim of
responsibility yet but the syrian regime
is likely to blame the opposition what
more do we know about what's happening
right now
well the authorities are calling this a
terrorist attack there has been no claim
of responsibility this explosion in the
heart of the syrian capital clearly a
security breach a bus carrying soldiers
was targeted so it was the military that
was targeted what we understand from
state media is that there were two
explosive devices that went off as the
bus was passing and according to them
there was a third explosive device that
did not go off and that they dismantled
it now the regime definitely has many
enemies when they use the word
terrorists they mean the opposition now
of course
the armed opposition is among the the
regime's enemies but they are largely
confined to the north of the country
also there's isil which continues to
operate in the center of syria and
engage in ongoing clashes with the
regime time and time again and of course
there's also divisions within the
security apparatus within the army
within the regime itself so we cannot
rule out any of that we can only
speculate but clearly the regime
believes it is the opposition just a few
minutes after
that explosion was reported heavy heavy
artillery shelling targeted a town in
ariha that's in the southern idlib
countryside the province is under the
control of the opposition we believe at
least 10 people were killed many of them
children on their way to school so this
is being seen as some form of
retaliation on the part of the regime
even though that this area comes under
regulatory irregular fire despite the
ceasefire that has been in place since
last year so the guns may have fallen
silent in syria the country remains
divided along front lines but still
there is no peace
zena hodger in beirut thank you very
much let's discuss this further now with
joseph deyer who's an affiliate
professor with the wartime and conflict
in syria project at the european
university institute is joining us via
skype from geneva very good to have you
with us joseph so blasts in damascus we
as we've said are rare they've been rare
in this 10-year conflict what does an
attack like this in the heart of the
syrian capital signal in your opinion
well even though we still lack
information on the whole picture of the
explosion this shows again once more
that we are very far from any kind of
stability
within syria and that
the regime is threatened by multiple
actors
this type of terrorist action is a
trademark of the so-called islamic state
which
i remind
although the end of the self-declared
caliphate in syria in early 2019 by the
joint forces of the us
and sdf did not mean the end of the
jihadist organization
which still posed a threat and a
security challenge especially after the
change of strategy of the islamic state
which largely focused on the suicide
attacks in civilian areas military
establishment targets in order to
destabilize
just as we've seen this morning cities
controlled by the regime
actually the international coalition
estimates the numbers of is islamic
state fighters between 8 000 to 16 000
in iraq and in syria so
even though as i said in introduction
we're still very far from having a clear
picture
um this shows once again that we're very
far from any form of stability in syria
whether politically militarily or
economically we're still
in a conflict situation i saw clearly a
threat as you say to the regime they
have targeted uh um army vehicles in the
past in the east but today in
retaliation as xena said there we have
the government forces bombing idlib uh
areas that are supposed to be uh covered
by the ceasefire which is agreed with
turkey and russia
what does it say about the government's
commitment to the ceasefire i mean are
they are they serious about negotiating
a piece
no we have to be clear about this this
is not the first time uh the good
tournament the same with women the same
regime has not respected the sales fire
well on the positive opposite the rule
is not respecting any kind of ceasefire
and the syrian regime has made very
clear that it wants to take back
all
territories uh in syria
and italy and this region has been the
italian has been bombarded on a
continuous um
on a continuous perspective
for months
they haven't been any kind of true
ceasefire uh again so i'm not surprised
and of this surprise and this is more in
the continuation of any of
all kind of disrespect of the regime
against these fires and targeting again
once again civilians in italy earlier
this week the opposition groups and the
syrian government agreed in geneva to
start drafting new constitutional
provisions
where does this all leave those
negotiations
well the negotiation occurring in geneva
and the constitutional community has
been a way
for the un and various international
powers to show that there is a so-called
negotiation ongoing but the syrian
regime has made clear on many
many times that what happens in geneva
stays in geneva and doesn't take into
account uh what is occurring basically
in geneva especially regarding the
constitutional committee bashar assad
made clear statement about this
especially in a period where the balance
of forces is very much
in favor of the syrian regime and
opposition is very weak
militarily politically and you have a
process as well of uh forms of
normalization especially between arab
states what we witnessed in the past few
months
regarding the the ira pipeline
so
lebanese uh ministry delegation sent by
the government for the first time since
the beginning of the conflict and
uprising uh egyptian ministries meeting
in the u.n with syrian ministry so
syrian regime clearly had the balance
since his favor thank you very much for
talking to us about this joseph dyer
joining us here from geneva thank you
for your time
thank you
meanwhile syrian refugees who have
returned home have faced severe human
rights abuses and persecution from the
government that's according to a report
by human rights watch it spoke with
syrians who returned from lebanon and
jordan between 2017 and 2021. the
organization documented cases of arrest
torture kidnappings extrajudicial
killings and enforced disappearances it
says returnees have struggled to meet
their basic needs